Emma this is all very difficult for the
Metropolitan Police yes third is on and
we're still talking about this Dreadful
case and we're again talking about the
failures uh by certain officers and the
investigation the original investigation
by the Metropolitan Police so as you say
five suspects named at the time two of
them convicted in 2012 so that took
nearly 20 years but there was always
this sixth person who hadn't been named
the fair-haired man now we know that
that sixth suspect was Matthew white a
man who had been brought in by the
police arrested twice in 2000 and 2013
but there was never deemed to be enough
evidence to bring charges against him
now it's emerged that police failings
meant that it took 20 years for them to
talk to a relative of white who'd
reported his presence at the scene at
the time so it took until a 2013 for
that to happen now Doreen Lawrence
Stephen's mother is furious about what
has happened and she feels that no one
is ever going to be brought to Justice
in terms of officers from that original
investigation and this is what she had
to say what is infuriating about this
latest Revelation is that the man who's
said to have led the murderous attack on
my son as evading Justice because of
police failures and yet not a single
police officers has faced or will ever
Face action the failure to properly
investigate a main suspect in a murder
case is so grave that it should be met
by serious sanctions only when police
officers lose their jobs can the public
have confidence that failure and
incompetence will not be tolerated and
that change will happen well we've heard
this afternoon from the mayor of London
Sadiq Khan who has given this response
to these latest Revelations
I'm shocked I'm angry but if I'm Frank
I'm not surprised I'm in this family
the Lawrence family have had to go
through years and years of discovering
yet further failings from the Police
Service deep institutional racially
driven failings and today's yet another
example of that and Dory Neville and the
entire family are in my thoughts today
wanted yet another apology from the
Metropolitan Police this time it's come
from the deputy assistant commissioner
Matt Ward this is what he had to say the
impact of the racist murder of Stephen
Lawrence and subsequent inquiries
continues to be felt throughout policing
unfortunately too many mistakes were
made in the initial investigation and
the impact of them continues to be seen
it is important to note that actually a
file was given to this Crown prosecution
service back in November of 2020 to
consider whether four officers involved
in that original investigation should
face criminal charges in relation to
their actions and no decision has yet
been made so it could well be that
Doreen Lawrence does get some further
justice yet